سنفهم اكثر تعقيدات السياسه الداخليه
الاسرائيليه حاليا في ظل المواقف اخر ما
سجل من مواقف اعود اليك دكتور مهند مصطفى
يعني قبل قليل نقل مراسل الجزيره عن
ان المجلس الامني
المصغر بدا للتو للبحث في موضوع مقترحات
باريس نريد ان نعرف ما هو التوجه حاليا
لان هناك اشارات متناقضه يطلقها نتنياهو
امام اهالي الا يقول انا مستعد للذهاب الى
صفقه حتى لو كلف ذلك الح الحكومه ومن ثم
يضع لاءات وخطوط حمر لا وقف للحرب لا
انسحاب من غزه لا افراج عن الاسرى ما الذي
يريده نتنياهو
حقيقه نعم نتنياهو يريد ان يحقق هدف واحد
اولا هو سوف يقبل الصفقه لانه مجلس الحرب
وافق على الص على الصفقه الان التحدي هو
في المجلس الوزاري المصغر ام الذي يضم
ايتام بينفي
وبت نتنياهو يحاول ان يخبر المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وتحديدا يحاول ان يوجه كلامه
لليمين الاسرائيلي ويقول لهم كالتالي انا
سوف اقبل هذه الصفقه سوف اقبل هذه الهدنه
ولكن كونوا متاكدين انني مستمر في الحرب
بعد ذلك هذا هو الخطاب الذي يحاول نتنياهو
ان يشرعن فيه قبول اسرائيل لهذه الهدنه
بمعنى انه يريد ان يقول لهم اننا الان سوف
نوقف الحرب من اجل
استرجاع الاسر والرهان الاسرائيليين اكبر
عدد منهم ومن ثم سوف استانف هذا الحرب هذا
هو الخطاب الذي يتحدث فيه
نتنياهو دكتور مهند هذا في الخط دكتور
مهند هذا في الخطاب المعلن ولكن ضمنيا هل
هذا ما ستوافق عليه اسرائيل بالنظر الى
كما ذكرت تاثير المؤسسات الشباك والمساعد
وغيرها والجيش
ايضا
انا اعتقاد انه الدوله العميقه في اسرائيل
وتيار كبير في داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
مع هذه الصفقه يعني يريد هذه الهدنه الان
البنيا موجود في معضله كبيره جدا علينا ان
نفهم
المعضله طبعا لا لا هدنه وقف اطلاق النار
بشكل كامل وشامل كما تريد حماس لا احد
يقبل حتى هذه اللحظه به باسرائيل هنالك في
اجماع في اسرائيل على استمر هذه الحرب
ولكن هنالك في ديناميكيات داخليه قد تح دث
بالنهايه قد تؤدي الى وقف اطلاق النار الى
وقف الحرب علينا ان نفهم هذه الديناميكيات
وهذه الديناميكيات نتنياهو يفهمها جيدا
ويدركها جيدا ولذلك هو في الايام الاخيره
يكثف من خطابه دعني اقول المتشدد فيما
يتعلق بهذه الصفقه المعدله الاساسيه لدى
نتنياهو هي مله كبيره جدا انا اعتقد ان
هذه اللحظه هي اكبر لحظه سياسيه معقده
يعيشها نتنياهو منذ بدايه الحرب على
المستوى الداخلي المعدله المتمثله بالتالي
اذا وافق على هذه الصفقه هذا معناه ان
اليمين المتطرف وبالذات حزب عظمه يهوديه
برئاسه بن كفير سوف يخرج من الحكومه الان
لبيد سوف
يعطيه لبيد رئيس المعارضه سوف يعطيه حمايه
وسقف من اجل الاستمرار بهذه الصفقه ولكن
لبيد لن يستمر معه طويلا في الحكومه بمعنى
انه سوف يعطيه غطاء لفتره معينه هذا معناه
انه اجلا ام عاجلا هذه الصفقه سوف تؤدي
الى نهايه نتنياهو السياسيه الى تفكيك
حكومته الان وجود هدنه طويله مثل هذا
الشكل ايضا سوف يؤدي الى احتجاج اليمين
على بنيامين نتنياهو هذا هذه الديناميكيات
الداخليه قد تؤدي بالنهايه الى اجراء
انتخابات في اسرائيل الى اسقاط الحكومه
اجراء انتخابات في اسرائيل الان حتى لو
بنيامين نتنياهو عرض هذه الصفقه فرضا انه
عرض هذه الصفقه واعلن ان اسرائيل لن توافق
عليها هذا الامر سوف يؤدي الى خروج جانس
من الحكومه جانس سوف يخرج من الحكومه
والاحتجاج جاج في اسرائيل سياخذ الان
منعطف مختلف تماما عن ما كان في السابق
لانه هذه هي اخر فرصه لاسرائيل لاستعاده
الاسر والرهائن لدى حركه حماس هذا
الاحتجاج لن يكون كما كان في السابق ايضا
بالنهايه سوف يؤدي الى انقسام غير مسبوق
في المجتمع الاسرائيلي حول اهداف الحرب
ولذلك كل هذه الديناميكيات الداخليه التي
يعيشها نتنياهو هي ضاغطه عليه بشكل كبير
ولذلك انا اميل ان نتنياهو سوف يوافق على
هذه الصفقه سوف يجازف سياسيا من خلال
الحفاظ على حكومته من خلال دعم المعارضه
ولكن مع التشديد في الخطاب حول تفاصيل هذه
الصفقه بالذات فيما يتعلق بالاسرى
الفلسطينيين وال المثابره بالحديث انه
مستمر في الحرب حتى القضاء على حركه حماس